Welcome to the presentation
on adding decimals.
Let's do some problems.
So let's say I had 0.008--
that's an 8-- 5 plus-- and
I'm writing it side by
side on purpose-- 1.799.
So at first you're like,
these decimals, they
confuse me, I give up.
But I'm going to show you
that it's actually very
straightforward and it's
actually no more difficult
than doing normal addition.
And there's only one thing
you have to think about
when you do decimals.
You have to line up
the decimal points.
So let's start with the first
number and let's rewrite it so
that we can actually
do the math.
0.0085.
Now for the second number let's
put the decimal point right
below where that first decimal
is on the top number, and
then rewrite the number.
So it's 1.799.
So all we did is we just
rewrote both numbers with their
decimal points lined up.
And we could've
flipped them around.
We could've written the 1.799
first and the 0.0085 below it.
What's key-- and if you get
this point and you already know
how to do addition, you've
already figured out how to do
adding decimals-- is that you
line up the decimal points.
So once we line up the
decimal points we're
ready to start adding.
But hey Sal, there's
something very strange
here you might say.
How can I add this
5 to a nothing?
Well there's a very
easy solution to that.
Let's just put a 0 right here.
And how can I do that?
How can I just randomly
augment a number with a 0?
Well, I don't know if I've
already shown you in another
module, but when you add
trailing 0's to decimals, it
doesn't really change the
value of the decimal.
And I think that
make sense to you.
If I said 1.10 that that's
the same thing as 1.1.
Which is the same
thing as 1.100.
It's all 1 and 1/10.
And these 0's just kind of add
extra digits of precision,
which actually, don't
change the actual value.
And maybe later when I'm
teaching computer programming
and computation, the
precision might matter.
But for now, it doesn't.
It's just the value.
So I added this 0 here and
you can always do that.
You can add trailing 0's
without actually changing
the value of the number.
And now we're really
ready to add.
5 plus 0 is 5.
8 plus 9 is 17.
1 plus 0 plus 9 is 10.
Carry the 1.
1 plus 0 plus 7 is 8.
And then bring down
this 1 because there's
nothing to add it to.
And we could have even
added a leading zero
here if you wanted to.
My wife's a doctor and she says
it's key that you always add
that leading 0 so that no one
gives someone the wrong
amount of medicine.
But anyway, so now
we are almost done.
We've done the addition and now
we just have to figure out
where to put the decimal point.
Well, the decimal point
just drops straight down.
And we're able to do that
because we already lined
up the decimal points.
So the answer to this
problem is 1.8075.
It seems complicated, but all
you have to do, line up the
decimal points, add 0's
where appropriate, and add.
And if you know how to add you
already know how to do this.
Let's do another problem.
58.75 plus 0.028.
Now if you saw a problem like
this written in this format,
your temptation might be to
immediately start adding.
Add the 5 to the 8, the 7
to the 2, the 8 to the 0.
And then just bring down the 5
or something of that nature.
And you would be wrong.
And I think you realize
why you'd be wrong.
Because you forgot
the first step.
The first step is line
up the decimal points.
When you're doing addition with
decimals, the number one step
is line up the decimal points.
So let's line up the
decimal points.
So we can just rewrite
that top number again.
58.75.
And now let's rewrite the
bottom number so that the
decimal points line up.
So we'll put the decimal
points right below it.
And it's 0.028.
And now we can add.
And just like before you
might say, how can I
add nothing to this 8?
We can add a trailing 0 to this
top number because it really
doesn't change the value of
the number and now it kind of
gives us a sense of security.
We have something
to add to the 8.
So let's do that.
0 plus 8 is 8.
5 plus 2 is 7.
7 plus 0 is 7.
8 plus blank space is 8.
And we could have added a 0
there and it would've been the
same thing, had the leading 0.
We wouldn't have given someone
the wrong about of medicine.
5 plus blank space is 5.
And we just drop down that
decimal point, and we're done.
It's that straightforward.
You line up the decimal points,
add any 0's that might make you
feel more comfortable because
it's often more comfortable to
add to a 0 than to add
to a blank space.
And then you do your addition
and then you drop down
the decimal point.
The answer is 58.778.
And it's always good to kind
of do a reality check.
To say, well, does my
answer make sense?
I have 58.75, so
roughly 58, almost 59.
58 and 3/4.
And I'm adding a very
small number to it.
I'm adding 0.028.
So my answer shouldn't
change much I guess is the
way you could view it.
It should still be around 58
something because I'm only
adding a very small amount.
If you had done it this way and
you had just started adding
immediately, you would
have gotten 59.
something.
And you're like, boy, but I
only added 0.028 not 0.28.
And you would've been a little
bit suspicious of your answer.
I hope I didn't confuse you,
but it's really healthy to
always think about the
magnitude of your numbers and
get a feel for just what you
are adding and not always
do it purely mechanical.
Although sometimes it is fun
just to chug through things.
Now let's do one more problem
just for good measure.
I have some time
left on the video.
102.1 plus 2.56.
So once again, think
about magnitude.
102.1 plus 2.56, that
should be like 104.
something.
I won't do it in my head.
We'll do it on paper.
So first thing, we line
up the decimal points.
102.1 plus-- line up the
decimal points-- 2.56.
Now we could add a trailing 0
here and we're ready to add.
0 plus 6 is 6.
1 plus 5 is 6.
2 plus 2 is 4.
0 plus nothing is 0.
1 plus nothing is 1.
Bring down that decimal point.
104.66.
It was that easy.
Hopefully it's easy.
I don't want to make you think
that it's easy if you're
finding it hard because
it actually is hard the
first time you do it.
But anyway, I think you're
ready now to try the module
on adding decimals.
I hope you have fun.